what type of skill and temperament does
the photographer need aside from just
great equipment uh well understanding
understanding the technical aspects of
the craft is obviously important you
have to be able to expose properly you
have to know the rules to break them i
know that's a stupid adage but you know
it's true you know if you if you're
going to light a certain way you should
have a reason for it um I think I really
want to keep keep breaking this back to
communication I think that really it's
you know I I consider myself a portrait
photographer so I'll go from my
perspective being a great portrait
photographer at least the ones that I've
seen the images that speak to me in the
successful images that I've made have
really come from great communication
it's really a matter of of visually
communicating what you're talking about
why you are why you're there I tend to
work with quite a few musicians and I
get a re interpret their music through
my photography so listening to the music
understanding it communicating with
their perspectives points of views there
there loves their hates their their
fears all of it and bringing that
together and I find that that
communication is where those details
come into line if that makes sense
you